the first Pennsylvania statewide
investigation into abuses by Catholic
priests is expected to be released any
day now the grand jury worked the grand
jury report details allegations against
more than 300 predator priests in six
diocese covering more than 1.7 million
parishioners Attorney General Josh
Shapiro led the 18 month long
investigation nikki beti spoke with
several victims who are speaking out
together for the very first time Nicki
good morning good morning dozens of
priests implicated in the
highly-anticipated report have gone to
court to try to keep their names from
being made public survivors and their
families tell us they've suffered
through decades of trauma they believe
the reports release will be an important
milestone in their fight for justice
it's a voice for the voiceless I felt
like the first time somebody really
listened this report is me getting my
life back saying these are the evil
bastards that stole my life
Sean Doherty julienne boards Jim Van
Sickle Mary McHale James Faliszek and
Judy Devon are among the more than 100
people who spoke to the pennsylvania
grand jury their stories fill a nearly
nine hundred page report how old were
you when your abuse began I was 10 13 14
16 through 18 17 18 16
my son was 15 when it started his hell
was right here on earth
Judy Devon says the death of her son
Joey three years ago can be traced to
what happened to him as a teenager
because of the way he was and I'm not
gonna say abused I'm gonna say the way
he was raped at age 17 his back was
injured there was nothing they could do
surgically and because of the pain
medication his death was caused by an
accidental overdose the word abuse gets
thrown around we're talking rapes Julie
Ann Burton Mary McHale both say they
were molested by priests at their
Catholic High School's my abuser when he
took his collar off he told me that he
could do whatever he wanted to do and he
believed I mean I believed him yeah
the collar is still the trigger for me
they murdered something in me something
died everything I believed died how many
of you believe that right now a child is
being abused at the hands of a priest
how does this happen it appears that
there's something in the DNA of the
church that encourages this Jamesville
ooh Zach says he witnessed the church's
secrecy and sex abuse cover-ups
firsthand not only as a victim but also
during his 18 years in the priesthood
you became a priest after being abused
by one why I felt called to be a priest
and it was almost as if it was a
completely separate issue as I made my
way through ministry it became very
clear to me that this was a systemic
issue it almost like a contagion that
this was an epidemic Jim Van Sickle
claims his high school English teacher
father David Paulson groomed and
sexually assaulted him from 1979 to 1982
he came forward this year after learning
Polson is facing trial on criminal
charges for abusing in the early 2000s
two other boys who are within the
statute of limitations I don't have the
right to do that because he's protected
by law you actually could see anger
frustration you finally get to a point
where you're willing to say it's time
for me to come and get you and the loss
is sorry you're abused but we're going
to protect about it a predator here
father Polson's attorneys tell CBS News
he is entitled to the presumption of
innocence and is saddened by the
allegations against him do you think the
statute of limitations should be
completely eliminated my statutes of
limitation ended from my abusive but to
me they're reusing me right now I want
the right to stand in court and face my
abuser and say just have them have them
go through the court process tell my
story make him listen to me I would say
to him why did you do this to me and I
believe his answer is going to be
because I can because I could the
survivors in Judy all say they are
longer practicing Catholics many of the
priests accused in the grand jury report
have died or retired the Pennsylvania
bishops insist they do not oppose the
release of the report several have
already published the names of accused
priests and apologized to victims how
brave of them Nicki to speak up so
candidly about something that's so
personal and so painful to them they
were incredibly powerful and I think
just being able to speak and maybe be
believed finally yeah was a little bit
of justice for them it was chilling to
when you said how many of you still
believe this is happening that they all
raised their hands they have no doubt at
all and I just want to add there is a
bill on the table in the Pennsylvania
legislature that could give a window
where there's no statute of limitations
and they could file civil lawsuits
because they say they're being rebuked
Nicki thank you very much